seven one four crunch crunch that's good
okay goddamn good friends man they're
good donors mom small I have a plus yeah
forget the game Aion that's a slice of
something pretzel yeah yeah one more
[Music]
barring the first yeah one more
are you a scientist yeah just eat a
pretzel one more one more I can't just
oh I'll wash down good too much pretzel
in my gob
[Music]
you feel like you're forgetting
something
all I'll do to it once now stuck all on
my teeth I still drive all right don't
drive right to really dry
yeah it's gonna take a bit Trilly in
their hand mitrik three Brian right he
tricked me
he took me i've been hand safe ride for
the dozen
look just like a good be a clip is just
send inside them
I still dry those borderline unpleasant
but get one more dry
[Music]